rhod Walker's sports columnist for The
Times Picayune the New Orleans advocate
kind enough to join us this morning
rod good morning thanks for joining us
what's the local reaction here with Drew
Brees from yesterday I think you sort of
saw it all over social media yesterday
what you saw the other athletes across
the country saying those are the same
sentiments here in New Orleans in fact
they had a protest here you know still
protesting here in New Orleans and there
was some chance of ever do Brees and
they didn't say if they he's saying what
M stands for and you know I I would have
never imagined that you'd hear that was
chants in the city of New Orleans I mean
you know how beloved rubriz is here so
that tells you you know just how
frustrated people were with hearing his
remarks on yesterday do you think he's
being unfairly attacked in this city no
because I think the timing of it and you
know it's fine if you mentioned when you
saw the article yesterday how you
thought it was an old that's exactly
what I thought too someone sent me the
Senate send me the link to it I said
this must be from 2017 and it wasn't it
was yesterday morning and I was just
shocked because of I mean there were
some that's being tone deaf I mean if
you look at what's been going on in this
country for the you know for the past 10
days I mean it's pretty clear that we
have a problem and the whole words out
there protesting and basically crying
for helping you know it's almost like he
just dismissed all of that with what
he's sailing yesterday yeah I think if
there would had been mention of
Minneapolis and George Floyd to go along
with his look we don't have to agree we
don't agree but that's the beauty of
this country we get that opportunity to
not agree I think the lack of public
awareness is what hurt drew brees here
and if you start with you know it's it's
unbelievable it's shocking it's a shame
that a man died in front of us
you know George Floyd and what these
protests are all those things and then
if you talk about your stance on the
flag okay at least you softened that a
little bit to have perspective there and
I was just surprised because drew Brees
is as media savvy as any athlete in
America here and and it was you know it
was disheartening because I do have
great respect for him I was just
surprised the teammates coming out
though
rod that Michael Thomas Malcolm Jenkins
how do you recover from that if you're
Drew Brees I think you took the first
step this morning you know just by
apologizing but I don't think this is a
quick fix I think this is like getting
cheated on by you you're afraid of
something take some time to heal and I
think he's going to uh you know I think
it's gonna take us some time and I think
I think the players may accept him
quicker than the fans will just because
the players at least they'll get a
chance to be around them every day and
they'll see if he's genuine and you know
if they believe it I mean I fans only
see Drew Brees on Sunday so for them you
know it'll be for the fans who we're
disappointed it takes some time for them
to get you know back on the Drew Brees
trying if I said you could sit down and
ask drew one question what would it be I
think that question would probably just
be what are you going to do to to show
that you know that your apology was
sincere and I don't know what you can do
there's nothing magical because now it's
it's not words
it's actions and he has shown a
willingness to help this community you
know the view nationally is he was there
and he stepped up and he donated money
and he's mr. New Orleans and I don't
know if he he recaptures that but it
feels like there's a little bit of work
that's left to be done and I don't know
what if I was his business partner
marketing agent PR person I don't know
what advice I would give Drew Brees
right now I don't know again I think
it's gonna be something that takes a lot
of time I think this deputy took today
with his apology you know he didn't
apologize for for hurting people he
apologized because he sound like you
really thought he was wrong and you know
you just got to hope that people believe
believe in what and what you're saying
and again it's his actions I mean he I
mean Drew's done more for this city than
than most people to ever come through
here I mean he's the most beloved
athlete ever come from New Orleans and
I'm you know so I mean he gets some
credit for that and that's something
that people definitely take into account
but I mean
still just it'll always be in the back
of people's mind I think and uh you know
10 15 years from now when we're talking
about Drew Brees you know you have to
wonder if people don't have that yeah
but you know that might be a part of his
mark rod good to visit with you we
appreciate your time as always thanks
for joining us
all right thanks Dan that's a rod Walker
sports columnist The Times Picayune